[Music]
if you're tired of all the futuristic
and space named call of duty games then
you might like the sound of this news
Activision has confirmed that this
year's Call of Duty is going back to its
roots I'm Matt this is a game spot news
update and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more coverage of virtual
guns that make loud noises during an
earnings call Activision coo Thomas
nipple said that in 2017 Activision will
take call of duty back to its roots and
traditional combat will once again take
center stage this is what our dedicated
community of Call of Duty players and
sledgehammer games which has been
developing this year's title are the
most excited about tickle called
infinite warfare a high quality
innovative game but he revealed that it
underperforms to Activision's
expectations no further details were
shared so we're not entirely sure if
going back to its roots means a more
classic setting like World War two a
more recent one is seen in the modern
warfare series or something else
entirely we'll keep you updated as more
is revealed but if you want some shooter
action right now you can check out our
video on the six teams we learned from
the Ghost Recon wildlands closed beta